- [Announcer] This Great
Big Story was made possible
by Wells Fargo, established 1852,
re-established 2018.
- [Narrator] Located in Altenburg, Austria
is a Benedictine abbey
with an unusually beautiful crypt.
The abbey is filled with well-known areas,
such as the striking
marble room, the library,
the chapel and the medieval monastery.
However, the one area that stands out
is the abbey's crypt.
(upbeat music)
Crypts are often dark,
subterranean homes of the dead,
but this crypt is bright,
and its walls are adorned
with beautiful art.
The detailed frescos were painted
by Austrian artist Paul Troger
in the 18th century.
At a distance, the imagery appears cheery.
However, death is in the details.
One wall features a
skeleton holding an arrow
aimed at cherubs, two
already slain at his feet.
Intricate images of Roman
gods in skeleton form
are also painted within massive murals.
Altenburg Abbey was built in
1144, but has been the site
of numerous invasions throughout history.
In 1645, a Swedish attack rendered it
in need of severe repair.
But despite these trials,
the abbey has remained active
and is a unique experience
for all that come to see it.
(relaxing music)